Welcome back to Curious Archive.
This video is the finale of my two-part series
on the biology of the video game Subnautica.
In these alien seas, breathtaking landscapes,
enormous predators, and unexpected mysteries
are all still waiting to be discovered.
And just like how life in earth’s oceans
gets stranger the deeper you dive, the depths
of Planet 4546B are far more extreme than
what’s on the surface.
They’re also highly dangerous… and I can
confidently say that this ranks among the
scariest experiences I’ve had while doing
fieldwork for the Archive.
But I’m determined to uncover the secrets
of this ocean.
So, ride with me in my deep-sea submersible
as we conclude this expedition into the unknown…
To the north, beyond the grassy plateaus,
huge Tree Mushrooms grow in abundance.
Despite their name and appearance, mushroom
trees are actually a particularly long-lived
species of coral.
In the shade of these ancient giants, a new
classification of life is swimming.
These are Jellyrays: an ethereal ray species
with highly translucent bodies.
In Earth’s oceans, translucent lifeforms
are quite common in the lower-light depths.
The jellyrays are a sign we’re getting closer
to the deeper — and more fantastical — regions
of 4546B.
Beyond the safety of the Mushroom Forest,
the twilight of the Bulb Zone awaits.
Here, the luminescent Bulb Bushes dominate
the landscape, and have evolved to grow in
this rocky, sandy environment thanks to a
highly advanced system of roots.
And along the sea floor, raging volcanic geysers
launch boiling liquid and chunks of molten
rock into the surrounding water.
The extreme heat from these geysers charbroils
any fish that swims too close.
An ominous light flickers in the murk.
The source is an ampeel: a huge, serpentine
predator covered with glowing prongs that
produce zaps of electricity.
These aggressive creatures use electric discharges
to intimidate other predators, and to kill
their prey with a single deadly shock.
Such living batteries might seem biologically
inexplicable, but the curious electric eel
on earth might help demonstrate how a creature
could produce electricity.
Electric eels use disc-shaped cells packed
into specialized organs to generate their
electric currents — as incredible as that
might sound.
It’s possible that the ampeel’s prongs
contain similar cells: although the bio-electricity
of the ampeel is far more extreme.
A series of screeches announces the approach
of a legion of Bonesharks.
Highly aggressive and territorial carnivores,
it’s unlucky to encounter so many at once.
Their thickly-armored exoskeletons which give
them their names are adapted not just to deter
larger predators, but also other Bonesharks.
The distinctive segmentation of these exoskeletons
suggests Bonesharks might share a distant
relative to the Sand Sharks we glimpsed on
our last outing.
If so, it’s a fearsome family tree.
While returning to the shallows to prepare
for the next leg of my journey, I spot a new
type of colorful fish.
Something about the way it looks is truly
hypnotic, and I want to swim closer, and closer…
And then it bites my nose.
That is a Mesmer, a sneaky little creature
that looks harmless while its four fins are
folded up, but unfurled can create hypnotic
patterns that have evolved to distract prey
while it goes in for the kill.
Thankfully, it seems I’m a bit too big to
be swallowed up — but this is one fish to
avoid.
With supplies replenished, it’s time to
venture further into the unknown.
Under the seafloor, networks of caves lead
deeper into the uncharted interior of planet
4546B.
Some of these caves are massive — and contain
entire ecosystems of their own.
And the Jellyshroom Cave is one of the most
miraculous.
Here, among the stalagmites, grow Jellyshrooms:
massive, highly luminescent ¬flora which
might be distantly related to the tiny acid
mushrooms of the shallows.
In the purple light of the Jellyshrooms shine
the Biters: small carnivores that stalk the
caves for small prey.
The antenna on their forehead seems to resemble
the deep-sea anglerfish’s lure at first
glance, but the Biter’s antenna actually
serves an entirely different purpose.
It contains olfactory organs that help it
detect bodily fluids in the water.
In other words, the Biter can smell its prey
anywhere in the cavern.
Unless, of course, the Biter becomes prey
itself.
Winding through the cave is an unsettlingly
lengthy Crabsnake: the apex predator of this
environment.
What makes this predator so deadly is not
just its size, but its ability to hide in
plain sight.
The Crabsnake has a symbiotic relationship
with the local Jellyshrooms: using their hollow
interior as the perfect lair from which to
ambush prey.
In behavior and appearance, the Crabsnake
somewhat resembles Earth’s Bobbit Worm:
an unattractive predator that also ambushes
its prey.
In the Jellyshroom caves, one needs to keep
an eye out…
Elsewhere on the seafloor, another shadowy
cavern beckons.
After many hours navigating the cave system,
I surface in a cave that, strangely, seems
to be lit by… daylight?
I realize I’ve stumbled upon something exceedingly
rare for planet 4546B: dry land.
This tiny island is the peak of an undersea
mountain connected to an aquatic cave system,
and it’s one of the few places on the planet
you can encounter terrestrial life.
Scuttling on the beach are Cave Crawlers.
As their name implies, these crab-like creatures
have evolved to crawl along the sides of cave
walls: which is likely why they are able to
adapt to this fleeting landmass relatively
quickly.
Analysis of their biology suggests they possess
a gas exchange membrane to breathe air, instead
of fully-functional terrestrial lungs.
Soaring overhead is a lifeform that has spent
much more time adapting to life.
This is a Skyray: an avian creature that has,
remarkably, evolved powered flight.
Although its wings give it some resemblance
to aquatic ray species, analysis shows no
particular genetic link.
Instead, the Skyray appears to have split
off the evolutionary tree much earlier than
most other species on the planet, perhaps
at a time when dry land was more prevalent…
In any case, it seems we’ve now seen all
the island has to offer.
Or… maybe not.
On one end of the island is a tremendous artificial
spire.
This mysterious monolith appears to be the
work of advanced extraterrestrials who, much
like myself, came to this planet from afar.
But did they come to study the life here,
or were their intentions more sinister…?
In any case, it seems this planet’s greatest
secret is still waiting to be uncovered…
To the south, the seafloor plunges lower than
ever before.
We have come upon the Grand Reef.
Here, orb-like blue plants called anchor pods
risk floating off due to their gas-filled
membrane — only staying in place due to
their net-like root system.
And nearby stomp a herd of Sea Treader Leviathans.
These vast herbivores roam the depths in search
of plants on which to graze.
The thunderous nature of their rhythmic steps
is truly something to experience.
Perhaps the most curious thing about these
creatures is the fact they have three legs
— something almost never glimpsed in nature.
Analysis suggests their front leg is actually
an elongated snout, used to siphon plant material
from the sea floor, and to maintain balance.
As alien as this might seem, there are some
species of Earth Tripod fish with elongated
fins that they use similarly to stand on the
sea floor.
Right now, it appears the Sea Treaders are
migrating, so it’s best not to disturb them…
Beneath the Grand Reef, caverns take us further
into the abyss.
Here, the intimidating Crabsquid waits to
butcher prey with its ten limbs.
Swim close to one, and they’ll unleash a
mysterious bio-electric discharge: which has
the properties of an electro-magnetic pulse.
While they appear to have massive brains,
analysis suggests the large organ within their
translucent sac is actually their stomach,
which the Crabsquid fill with their bio-luminescent
prey.
As a result, they seem attracted to light
sources, convincing me to make a hasty exit
from my submarine.
This turns out to be a good call, as it drags
my submarine into the depths.
If there are other creatures like the Crabsquid
on the prowl, I’m going to need something
a little larger...
For the next perilous leg of the journey,
I’ll be piloting a ‘Cyclops’ submarine:
a vehicle that should be able to withstand
the crushing depth of the abyss.
Below the deep Grand Reef awaits a surreal
environment of eerie green fog.
This is the Lost River, a region covered in
alkaline brine pools, which give the illusion
of an underwater stream.
Brine pools also exist in Earth’s oceans,
and are extremely toxic due to their high
salinity.
Best not to get too close…
Above these pools drift the haunting Ghost
Rays.
Relatives of the Jellyrays from the Mushroom
Forest, in these extreme depths, the Ghost
Rays have become almost completely transparent,
to the point where you can see the red of
their internal organs.
Elsewhere in the Lost River, Blood Crawlers
— the spindly relatives of the Cave Crawlers
— stride above the brine on stilt-like legs.
Rather unsettling forms of life…
In the central chamber, something truly horrifying
is waiting.
Or rather, it would be if this leviathan were
still alive.
This ancient fossil belonged to a colossus
far larger than any that currently swims through
the seas.
Indeed, it is so massive that its ribs have
become part of the Lost River’s landscape.
We should count ourselves lucky this unknown
genus seems to have gone extinct long ago…
Yet still alive are the River Prowlers.
These aggressive, transparent predators haunt
the gravesite of the leviathan like vengeful
ghosts.
Even more frightening, their four head-tendrils
can lash out when attacking, allowing them
to pull in prey.
Not the sort of creature you’d like to encounter
in the dark.
But there is a strange beauty to certain regions
of the Lost River.
In a cove under the central chamber, the brine
becomes a harmless blue, and Ghost Rays flock
around a massive tree.
This tree appears to be an ancient nesting
ground, as it has grown around a giant bio-luminescent
egg.
While the egg is beautiful, whatever hatches
out of an egg that size might not be…
To find the adult form of the huge creature
that hatches from this egg, we must venture
into the nightmarish darkness of the Dead
Zone.
Here, at the edge of the habitable region
for most fauna lives, we’ve found our giants…
or they’ve found us.
These aggressive monsters are Ghost Leviathans,
and they’re a major threat to this expedition.
Analysis of their jaws suggest they feed on
microscopic lifeforms that help them reach
their massive sizes — although they also
seem fully capable of feeding on something
larger.
Time to head back the way we came…
The mystery of the giant egg has been solved,
but that’s not the only strange thing in
the Lost River.
These ruins of a massive alien structure resemble
the one on the island.
The structure is guarded by these lifeforms,
the Warpers — who possess a mind-bending
ability.
At will, they can somehow fold spacetime and
vanish into portals.
This is not the ability of a natural lifeform
—it seems we are dealing with an artificial
creation.
Searching for answers, I enter the ruined
building.
In here, we can see the unfinished artificial
body of a Warper — confirming that they
did not evolve naturally, and are a creation
of extraterrestrials.
But for what purpose?
Translating a digital message, it seems these
alien architects came to 4546 B many years
ago searching for a cure for a disease, and
the Warpers are their artificial quarantine
enforcers.
Given the lack of any living architects on
4546 B, it appears that they were unsuccessful…On
a table in a nearby lab, they’ve left behind
the egg of a curious creature.
After returning to the surface to recharge
my submarine, I hatch the egg and this delightful
lifeform emerges.
This is a Cuddlefish: a friendly, rotund little
creature that displays high levels of intelligence
and curiosity.
I’ve also found it’s quite a fan of treats.
Analysis suggests it’s possible this creature
has been imported from another world — or
even genetically altered to be extra friendly.
It’s possible the architect aliens kept
them as pets just as we do with dogs.
It’s tempting to stay with the Cuddlefish
in the shallows, yet I can’t help but feel
that in the abyss, there are more mysteries
I’ve yet to solve…
Beneath the Lost River, the landscape blazes
with the fiery glow of molten rock.
We’ve reached the Lava Zone: the deepest
environment of them all.
Here, incredible, heat resistant forms of
life have evolved: like the Crimson Ray — a
ray species that has developed a mottled coloring
to help it blend in with the lava.
And the Magmarang: a relative of the Boomerang
with a beautiful glowing tailfin.
Another remarkable form of life is the Lava
Larva, a grub-like creature that feeds off
geothermal and electrical energy.
I first learned this fact when I found one
stuck to the windshield of my cyclops, draining
its energy.
While this behavior is somewhat annoying,
the energy-conversion capabilities of this
creature are truly remarkable.
On the molten floor is something highly alarming.
These skeletons belong to Reaper Leviathans
like the one we encountered on our last expedition.
Although picked clean, these skeletons belong
to recent kills.
It seems that somewhere in the Lava Zone is
a predator so large it can drag Reaper Leviathans
into the depths.
This doesn’t bode well...
Basking in the red glow of the molten rock
are Lava Lizards.
These predators are too small to be our culprits,
but they’re nonetheless quite deadly.
For defense, they are able to cover their
bodies with hardened lava like natural armor.
While such a behavior is far more extreme
than anything on Earth, Scaly Foot Snails
— which I’ve discussed on this channel
before — can survive in volcanic vents by
incorporating iron scales into their body
like medieval armor.
However, Lava Lizard biology takes this to
a new level.
At the end of the Lava Zone lurks a massive
chamber.
The loudest roar we’ve encountered on our
voyage shakes the cavern.
We’ve found our Reaper Leviathan slayer.
This is a Sea Dragon Leviathan, the largest
predator in Subnautica.
Possessing both arms and tentacles, these
creatures exceed 350 feet, or 112 meters in
length.
Sea Dragons get their name from their ability
to consume molten materials and expel them
at their adversaries like they’re breathing
fire.
I can only hope this absurdly deadly lifeform
doesn’t notice me... no such luck.
A huge blow from the leviathan rocks the cyclops
submarine.
As a result, there appears to be a… ‘minor’
leak.
Out of options, I have to abandon ship.
Luckily, I have one last hope in the Prawn
Suit: a deep sea mechanical walker that should
make an ideal escape pod.
Ejecting from the cyclops, it’s a bit of
a drop to the bottom.
But it appears my plan has worked, as the
Sea Dragon Leviathan thinks its foe has been
vanquished.
Here, at the end of our journey, lies a final
mysterious building.
With some difficultly, I pilot the Prawn Suit
over to it.
Inside, locked in a containment facility,
the largest creature in Subnautica is waiting.
This is a Sea Emperor Leviathan, and although
it appears to be a relative of the Sea Dragon,
it is in no way hostile.
Like real-world baleen whales, the largest
creatures on earth, its diet consists solely
of microorganisms.
While the Sea Emperor Leviathan is so large
that I am unable to get a proper scan of it,
it seems that it can manipulate neurons to
communicate telepathically — as it told
me of its plight.
The Sea Emperor was entombed here by the alien
architects in the hopes it could provide a
cure for their disease — which I believe
is in strict violation of the intergalactic
code of biological ethics.
At the request of this intelligent creature,
I agree to take its hatchlings back to the
surface with me.
Watching the first moments of baby Sea Emperors’
lives is a truly wonderous experience: even
after all the biological marvels I’ve glimpsed
thus far.
Sadly, the Sea Emperor is at the end of its
lifespan, and informs me it won’t be coming
with us.
At the very least, I’m happy I can help
their babies live on in freedom.
It is a bittersweet conclusion to a long and
winding journey…
With the Sea Emperor babies returning to their
natural habitat, our study of this region
of Subnautica is at its end.
There are other worlds waiting for us, and
the time has come to return to the stars.
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support and like, subscribe, and hit the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things Curious.
See you in the next video.